It's hard to believe, but it's been it's been
15 years since The Ring was released.
And in that time, this girl…
...somehow turned into this girl.
Would you believe the actress who starred
as the waterlogged ghost gal is actually a
normal person in real life?
Here's what Daveigh Chase has been doing since
she first scared the pants off of us.
Young breakout
Take away all the makeup and CG corpse effects,
and Chase was — big surprise — a normal
kid.
Well, a normal kid with a growing Hollywood
career.
The year before The Ring was released, Chase
voiced the lead in the English dub of Spirited
Away and co-starred in Donnie Darko as Donnie's
younger sister, Samantha.
In 2002, in addition to starring in The Ring,
but she also voiced Lilo in Lilo & Stitch.
She reprised her role for two Lilo & Stitch
video games, as well as the Lilo & Stitch
cartoon series, from 2003 to 2006.
Other roles
Chase had a memorable arc as the troublemaking
teen bride Rhonda Volmer on the HBO show Big
Love from 2006 to 2011.
She's also appeared on TV shows like CSI,
ER, Charmed, Cold Case, and Without A Trace,
and reprised her role from Donnie Darko in
the 2009 sequel, S. Darko.
Her most recent projects have been independent
films, including American Romance and Jack
Goes Home.
L.A. life
Though she grew up in Albany, Oregon, Chase's
Instagram feed could easily double as a tourism
guide for Los Angeles, where she currently
lives.
Her views of the skyline alone could be used
for a brochure.
The bulk of Chase's Instagram account is dedicated
to all the time she spends with animals, but
she still has a sense of humor about having
once been a young horror icon, as evidenced
by one Instagram post asking, "Should I be
a slutty Samara for Halloween?"
Hospital drop off
On Feb. 15, 2017, Chase's real life became
a scene from a movie.
TMZ reported that Chase rushed a dying man
to a hospital in Los Angeles, left him outside,
then left the scene.
The site reported that Chase may have been
hanging out with him that day.
When police ran Chase's name, they discovered
an outstanding warrant for her arrest in an
unrelated case.
According to the New York Daily News, Chase
is "not a suspect in the death and authorities
have reason to believe the man overdosed and
the actress was just trying to get him to
the hospital."
Arrest warrant
Leaving a dying man outside a hospital is
an unusual move, but it's possible that Chase
didn't want to draw any attention to herself,
seeing as she had a warrant out for her arrest
at the time.
Fox News reported that Chase was arrested
on February 22, 2017 for a traffic-related
violation.
According to Fox News, she was also questioned
about the unidentified man's fatal overdose,
but at the time of this video, she does not
face any charges in connection with that death.
On the road
While Chase had several filming projects in
2016, her schedule for 2017 looks totally
open.
From the looks of her Instagram, she's been
spending time out on the road in an RV and
generally staying pretty far from the bright
lights of Hollywood.
Whether the former child star is finished
with acting for good or just taking a break
for awhile, we can always go back and spend
some quality time with Samara Morgan.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!